derrière le problème de la croissance
le nouveau gouvernement est directement
confronté à la question de la stratégie
énergétique à long terme les travaux
économétriques le démontre il y à une
étroite corrélation entre la croissance
et l'énergie disponible par habitant ce
lien entre l'énergie et la croissance
est encore plus vrai pour le pétrole or
l'approvisionnement pétrolier de la
france un des croître inexorablement
c'est ce que nous explique jean marc
jancovici ingénieur l'école
polytechnique consultants et cofondateur
du cabinet carbone 4
jean marc jancovici et là des
spécialiste reconnu des questions de
l'énergie du climat et de l'économie du
carbone
alors où un nouveau gouvernement rentre
en fonction une des questions qu'on peut
légitimement se poser est de savoir
quelles vont être ses marges de
manoeuvre en matière économique le plus
vraisemblable pour les cinq ans qui
viennent et en fait malheureusement pour
beaucoup plus longtemps que ça et que
nous n'allons plus retrouver de
croissance économique ou du moins plus
de croissance économique significative
la raison à cela elle a démarré il ya 35
ans au moment des chocs pétroliers
il s'agit tout simplement du fait qu' il
y a un lien extrêmement fort et
malheureusement méconnu entre l'énergie
est ce qu'il est coutume d'appeler le
pib alors physiquement le système marche
comme suit le pib c'est la contrepartie
monétaire de la production la production
repose sur des flux physiques et pour
créer ces flux physiques il faut de
l'énergie
quand on observe la corrélation
historique dans tous les pays ocde entre
l'approvisionnement énergétique et le
pib on constate qu'elle est absolument
excellente en fait bien meilleure que la
corrélation du pib avec n'importe quoi
d'autre
et il est possible de spéculer sur
l'approvisionnement énergétique future
de l'europe et donc de la france
et d'en déduire que malheureusement le
pib français
devraient pas croître et en tout cas pas
croître des 2 à 2 5% espérés par le
candidat nouvellement élu dans les
années qui viennent pour être un peu
plus précis en europe les deux tiers de
l'approvisionnement énergétique viennent
du pétrole et du gaz 40% de l'énergie
européenne c'est du pétrole 25%
c'est du gaz en ce qui concerne le
pétrole l'approvisionnement européen a
commencé à décroître depuis 2005 et donc
en france avant le grenelle de
l'environnement
la conséquence de ce déclin c'est le
plafonnement de la production pétrolière
mondiale depuis 2005
à partir du moment où la production
globale est stable et où la france qui
est un importateur historique se
retrouvent en compétition croissante à
la fois avec la production avec la
consommation domestique des pays
producteurs et avec les pays émergents
et bien la quantité de pétrole à
laquelle la france peut accéder est en
baisse c'est également valable pour les
importations européennes qui
représentent 70% de la consommation de
pétrole du vieux continent
donc depuis 2005 nous avons une énergie
qui est orienté à la baisse de manière
contrainte sur le pétrole et on peut
presque répéter l'histoire sur le gaz
25% de l'énergie européenne donc c'est
du gaz 60 % vient de la mer du nord et
la mer du nord a entamé son déclin
là aussi il y a quelques années ce
déclin est lent pour le moment mais
d'ici 2015 à 2020 quand la norvège qui
est le dernier grand pays producteur de
la zone qui n'a pas passé son pic va
passer son maximum de production alors
le déclin derrière sera rapide et
absolument pas compensés par des
exportations russes ou par des
importations de gaz naturel liquéfié
on va donc se retrouver avec une énergie
à la disposition des européens qui va
baisser et donc à cause du lien entre
énergie et pib avec un pib européen qui
va au mieux rester à peu près stable et
plus vraisemblablement baisser cela
rentre frontalement en contradiction
avec les chiffres qui ont servi au moins
publiquement à base et les promesses du
nouveau président puisque dans ses
engagements de campagne 60 très
exactement il était stipulé page 40 que
la croissance française se promènerait
entre 2 et 2
ni % à partir de 2015 voire même 2014
et bien évidemment cette affaire là
n'arrivant pas une des premières
questions qui se posent au gouvernement
sait que faire alors que la croissance
ne reviendra pas alors ce que faire va
évidemment impacté tout un tas de dire
tout un tas de domaines d'action dans
lequel le gouvernement doit prendre des
décisions
ça va impacter bien évidemment tous les
système redistributif
à commencer par les retraites ça va
aussi impacté les marges de manoeuvre
qui sont disponibles pour relancer ou
l'industrie ou les transports ou d'une
manière générale tout ce qui nécessite
de l'argent investi par la puissance
publique
bref ça va poser tout un tas de
questions qui pour le moment n'ont pas
été posées de manière franche avant
l'élection présidentielle et donc vont
devoir être posée après que faire dans
ce genre de contexte
la logique voudrait que si notre
économie actuelle est sous perfusion de
combustibles fossiles et bien à une
chance de se réaliser tout projet qui
suppose d'en consommer de moins en moins
et a peu de chance de se réaliser
tout projet qui suppose d'en consommer
de plus en plus dit comme ça ça paraît
assez triviale en fait ça mais une ligne
de séparation des eaux assez nette
et il est possible de regarder catégorie
par catégorie
ce que ça signifie en termes concrets on
peut commencer par exemple par les
villes il est évident que en période
énergétique contraintes notamment sur le
pétrole
on va devoir faire des villes qui seront
plus dense mieux réparties sur le
territoire est probablement qu'ils
occuperont un peu moins de gens ou dans
lesquels il y aura une fraction un peu
réduite des gens qui trouveront à
s'employer
parce que les villes se sont créés dans
tous les pays industrialisés
parce que les campagnes se sont vidés
grâce à l'énergie abondante et parce
qu'on avait besoin de plus en plus de
gens dans les échanges
à partir du moment où la production elle
aussi permise par une énergie abondante
aller en augmentant
il va également falloir faire des choses
sur les moyens de transport donc
diminuer la consommation de pétrole par
voiture et mettre en place des systèmes
qui n'ont pas besoin de pétrole
correspond au sens de l'histoire
a contrario essayer de faire redémarrer
une industrie automobile basé sur des
performances qui sont conservés donc dit
autrement des consommations par voiture
qui restent identiques devraient se
heurter à des limites physiques
croissante dans le domaine de
l'industrie
il devient essentiel de décarbonés
l'industrie lourde le plus vite possible
alors l'industrie lourde très
concrètement ses aciéries cimenteries
chimie papeterie métallurgie des non
ferreux et ses industries lourdes si
elle reste dépendant des combustibles
fossiles
il leur sera de plus en plus difficile
d'exister en europe et si l'europe perd
son industrie lourde elle perdra
derrière son industrie manufacturière ou
plus exactement elle aura de plus en
plus de mal à conserver son industrie
manufacturière décarbonés l'industrie
lourde et quelque chose qui ensuite peut
s'exporter et donc peut contribuer à
l'équilibré de la balance commerciale
tout comme le fait d'être les premiers à
savoir construire des modes de transport
qui sont adaptés aux futures et non pas
au passé tout comme le fait de savoir
construire ou reconstruire des villes
qui sont adaptés aux futures et non pas
au passé tout comme le fait de savoir
construire des réseaux qui sont adaptés
aux futures et non pas au passé donc
d'une manière générale à partir du
moment où on décide de décarbonés
l'économie on se rend compte que c'est
quelque chose d'extrêmement structurant
pour savoir quels sont les projets
industriels et les projets d'activités
qui ont une chance de déboucher dans le
monde futur et de nous permettre
d'occuper en premier les places
intéressantes et les projets pour
lesquels ça ne passera pas la barrière
de l'énergie rare et donc il vaut mieux
réfléchir dès à présent à la bonne
manière de reconvertir les gens qui s'y
trouvent